Hey, how's it going bros? This is Pewdiepie!
Pokemon Go... I can't stop playing, I'm level 25...
My legs hurt though.
What does everyone want from Pokemon Go? What is the one thing that we're all missing?
That's right. To play from your computer.
That's what we're gonna do today.
Now, you may think we hacked the game...? Fuck that, we're not cheaters.
Right Micheal?
Michael: We're not cheaters.
That's right, we're not cheaters.
Marzia bought one of these very expensive... [Laughs]
...drones. To shoot videos with.
I... I could..- The audio.
I was allowed to borrow this. But if I break it...
...she's literally going to kill me.
So we're gonna put my phone on this! [Laughs]
And we're gonna play Pokemon Go... remotely.
Let's do it. [Laughs]
So 13 days ago, someone posted this. I didn't see it until now...
But someone's already attempted this.
But we don't have any proof. All right, we're gonna actually do this shit.
He's asking: is this cheating?
We're about to find out.
We're gonna duct tape... my Samsung S7, I love so dearly, to this very other expensive piece of equipment.
Hopefully nothing goes wrong. Let's do it.
So right now I'm duct-taping my phone, underneath the drone.
...as securely as I can.
I'm actually really nervous. But I think that's pretty good actually!
Like, out of all the stupid ideas...
...this is by far the best one. [Snorts]
So the idea is that the drone is gonna move us to a location where there is a lot of Pokemons.
Then there's a program, by my computer, where I'll be sitting here controlling the drone, looking at the footage,.
...while at the same time I'll see my screen on my computer... Catching Pokemons.
The way the game was made...
This is how Nintendo visioned this game to be played by everyone.
Now, there are a couple things that may or may not go wrong... [laughs]
Is it powerful enough to lift this phone?
I don't know.
Is the phone gonna stick?
These are very powerful fans, you know?
Could this go wrong? Yes. Let's just keep--let's just do-- let's just do it.
There's only one way to find out, let's just do it.
[Reading] "Update firmware?" Don't make me laugh.
Alright, here we go.
There we are. Hi.
We're live. Alright, drone.
Make me proud!
Now go and catch some Pokemons!
We're in our phone. That's on the drone.
Opening the Pokemon Go app.
Oh, we got a lot of Drowzees nearby!
Oh, it's making clicks, and shit. I didn't click for that.
Maybe the tape is like, fuckin' up the display a lil' bit?
We ran into a problem right away, didn't we! [wheezes]
The touch screen is fucked, because of the tape, so we have to put something in between.
[Plastic rustling] Luckily, we found one of these.
Fits perfectly.
No... touch screen is working
Who needs... a thirty dollar case when PewDiePie can make one for you, uh...
Just $29.99, alright? Much better quality.
[French accent] Second attempt!
This looks like a fuckin' bomb, doesn't it?
[Seagulls cawing] Alright, it's time to fly.
[Fans whirring]
[Pewds, under the noise] Oh my God!
[Fans whirring, seagulls cawing]
[Offscreen yawn]
[Pewds, shouting] Go, Pokemon!
Marzia's gonna kill me...
If I fuck this up.
Let's not fuck it up.
[Laughing] The drone is stabilized.
[Unintelligible talking]
Okay. Here we go.
We're flying freestyle.
Oh my fucking God, I am SWEATING.
I am SWEATING! [chuckles]
Fucking--Oh! [Scrambling for words] Mission gone!
Nope!
Oh, it's still--It's still there.
[Sad piano]
We're switching phones
Because the Samsung is so--
...Maybe it's the edge screen? I don't know, but it's so sensitive to, like...
Touch--touch, or whatever?
Even though we try and pack it nicely
So we're gonna try it with a Sony, see if that works.
Plus, I got this one for free, so if it falls off...
It's less of a pain.
Honestly, I'm suprised we didn't do this right before [laughs]
What do you think about this?
Michael: "Ooooooh shiiiiiit"
Pewds: Yeah. Yeah, this should work, right?
Michael: "The box"
Why did we not do this-- this is like-- that looks fuckin' GOOD.
This looks like a pro did it.
We've been goin' for about an hour and a half [laughs]
So far we put the phone in the air, but no Pokemon.
[Sighs] Alright. It's gonna rain soon.
Starting up. [Drone beeps]
The camera realizes that it can't move.
[Pathetic drone noises]
[Michael, laughing] "Oh no!"
Come on, camera.
We have to move it backward a little bit, maybe?
[Michael, laughing] "So cute!"
Pewds: You think this is funny?
Michael: "It's fuckin' h--"
Pewds: You think this is FUNNY? ...Goddammit!
[Sad piano]
Alright, Michael thinks it's okay.
[Clicking] Yeah, we're in. [Loud clank] Jesus! Wh--
[Whirring]
[Seagulls cawing]
Get me my FUCKING charizard!
Alright. Now, we're gonna get over there.
There we go.
[Intense music]
[Sudden change to sad piano]
[Music resumes] Michael: Go!
But where are the Pokemons?
Let's plu-- let's put a bait on that one.
[Intense music continues]
This is working pretty good, man.
[Music stops] Oh! We got a Drowzee.
[Music resumes] Here we go.
Swiping--
We got it!
Okay, we got it in the Pokeball! [Claps]
WE GOT IT! [Celebratory music] Yes!!! [Laughs]
Where's the drone, seriously? Ok there it i--[laughs]
[Pewds, quietly, laughing] ...So funny, [unintelligible]
Pewds: Oh God, it's going so high!
Okay, we-- we got what we came for [laughs] let's get it back pl--
For a fuckin' Drowzee, man!
Now let's get this baby home safe!
[Drone whirring]
PERFECT LANDING!!! Hoooo yeah!!!
We got a Drowzee! [laughs]
[Quietly, laughing] ...So fuckin' dumb!
[Breathes in] Okay! [Laughs] Fuckin' [unintelligible]
There it is. [Laughs] It's a fuckin' Drowzee
Ohhhhh, dude.
Now I know how they felt like when they landed on the moon-- [Laughs]
Alright, so we did it! We caught a Pokemon, while using a drone
I know it's not much, but... I still think that was pretty cool
I didn't think we would actually be able to DO it!
This is my second time ever flying a drone,
and I was kinda scared of--of just--losing the drone
If you have more experiences with drones, you could TOTALLY...
...pull this off.
Especially if you wanna HATCH EGGS.
Heyy...
But that was pretty much it, I hope you bros enjoyed!
Leave a like, and we might try some more weird shit like this [laughs]
And as always, thanks for watching [kisses fist]
[Deep, gruff voice] Stay awesome, bros.
[Intense music]
They said I would never catch it.
But they were WRONG.
THERE IT IS!!
OH MY GOD!! OH MY GOD!!!!
Cameraman,
It's been a pleasure working by your side.
But once I go in, I won't make it back.
"What do you mean, 'go in'?"
[Trails off]